[Música]
cuántos kilos han perdido en la dieta
más exitosa que han hecho en su vida
246 kilos
investigando encontré que el peso
recomendado y realista que una persona
puede perder un año siendo dieta es más
o menos el 5 por ciento de su peso esto
para el peruano promedio serían más o
menos tres kilos y medio al año si
alguien viniera y nos dijera que perdió
seis kilos haciendo dieta todos digamos
guau como hizo seguro se la pasa en el
gimnasio o sacrifico mucho pollito a la
brasa
saben ustedes cuántos kilos perdió el
venezolano por medio del 2017
10 kilos
10 kilos en un año
estos señores significan hambre
el diccionario define el hambre como una
sensación dolorosa un estado de
debilidad causado por la necesidad de
comer hace que las personas nos pongamos
irritables temblorosas débiles y
desorientadas con una sensación de dolor
y vacío en el estómago durante periodos
prolongados el hambre activa a nuestros
instintos más básicos de supervivencia
hace que sintamos de cerca la
posibilidad de morir es agonía
incertidumbre angustia
ahora imagínense como esta angustia se
ve multiplicada si sabemos que las
personas que más amamos en el mundo
nuestros padres nuestras parejas
nuestros hijos sienten tanta hambre como
nosotros
esta situación sumada a otras igual de
graves como la tasa de homicidios más
alta del mundo y una de las peores
hiperinflación es alguna vez registrada
han hecho que millones de venezolanos
salgan de su país qué harían ustedes si
ésta fuera la situación de sus países
caminarían los tres mil trescientos
kilómetros que hay de aquí hasta la
frontera con venezuela cruzaría en el
continente
por mi familia por mi hija yo caminaría
hasta la mismísima patagonia con tal de
volver la esperanza
desde el 2016 latinoamérica enfrenta un
éxodo sin precedentes más de 4 millones
de mujeres hombres y niños han salido de
venezuela haciendo de esta la segunda
situación de movilidad humana en pobla
de población vulnerable más grande del
mundo después de la crisis siria más del
80% de ellos se encuentran aquí en
latinoamérica en países como colombia
perú ecuador y chile al principio y
recaban con suficientes recursos para
instalarse e invertir desde hace dos
años más y más van llegando en buses o
caminando los miles de kilómetros de
montañas valles ríos y páramos que
separan sus hogares en venezuela de esos
múltiples destinos al salir ellos dejan
atrás sus familias sus amigos sus
trabajos sus profesiones y sus
pertenencias dejan todo lo que son y
todo lo que tienen
salen buscando un futuro incierto que
espera que esté lleno de oportunidades
pero el camino es arduo y lleno de
peligro más de 500 venezolanos han
perdido la vida tratando de emigrar sólo
este año ahogados en accidentes de
tránsito de frío en las cordilleras
caminan por semanas arrastrando sus
maletas con su mente puesta en su
destino final y al llegar muchos se
abrazan de alegría por haber logrado su
meta pero esta euforia es seguida por la
sobrecogedora de su realidad donde van a
vivir
de que van a comer que le van a mandar
los suyos a pesar de esta incertidumbre
siguen luchando por algún día volver a
hacer quienes fueron y si llegan a los
lugares más prósperos que los que dejan
pero no por eso con toda su red
necesidad de resueltas llegan a países
como el mío colombia que día a día lucha
por superar los estragos que más de 60
años de conflicto armado interno le han
dejado a países como ecuador que se
recupera de una recesión económica o
como el perú que a pesar de haber dado
pasos agigantados para reducir la
pobreza todavía enfrenta brechas
importantes en salud y educación
y los lugares a los que llegan cambian
nuestras comunidades están cambiando
encontramos interacciones que antes no
teníamos nosotros como ciudadanos de
ellos llegábamos a un almacén oa un
restaurante y nos atendían personas de
nuestro país
ahora nos atienden extranjeros y como no
más del 50% de los venezolanos en el
perú están empleados en los sectores de
hoteles restaurantes y comercios
y este cambio es inevitable siendo es
una población que huye ellos van a
seguir saliendo de venezuela y van a
seguir viniendo a nuestros países sea
como sea
entonces si nuestras sociedades están
cambiando y este cambio no lo podemos
evitar tenemos que tomar una decisión
podemos y debemos tomar acciones que nos
lleven a poder transformar esto en una
oportunidad para desarrollo
el tema es que esas decisiones están
mediadas por una cantidad de mitos que
como buenos mitos no son ciertos pero
que terminan guiando nuestra manera de
actuar desde el banco mundial de venimos
desde hace años analizando las
implicaciones que tienen este tipo de
fenómenos en los países receptores y
acompañándolos a ellos y a las
comunidades receptoras a poder
transformar estos retos en oportunidades
de desarrollo para esto o en medio de
esto hemos podido derrumbar algunos de
los mitos que más frecuentemente nos
llevan a tomar decisiones
beneficiosas
mito 1 ya son muchos esto lo escuchamos
todo el tiempo en los países receptores
ya son muchos están por todos lados pero
en verdad son tantos como nos parecen
veamos en colombia el país que más
población migrante ha recibido 3 de cada
100 personas son venezolanos en el perú
serían más o menos dos y medio de cada
100 y en ecuador' serían 2 de cada 100
en el líbano un país con un producto
interno igual a una fracción del de perú
y 26 veces más personas por kilómetro
cuadrado 17 de cada 100 son refugiados
sirios es el país del mundo que más
refugiados ha recibido y lo sigue
recibiendo por razones humanitarias así
vistos no parecen tanto es verdad
mito 2 nunca hemos recibido tanta gente
ni mucho menos tan vulnerable
veamos durante la migración china 5 de
cada 100 personas en el perú habían
nacido en ese país
este proceso nos dejó cosas deliciosas
como el chifa pero también nos dejó
empresarios chefs poetas escritores
medallistas olímpicos y hasta campeonas
de marinera
se estima que el 10 por ciento de la
población peruana tiene origen chino
si estos chinos hoy son más peruanos que
la papa porque no podría pasar lo mismo
con los venezolanos con quien
compartimos el idioma y la cultura
latina
hablemos ahora de las poblaciones
vulnerables colombia ha recibido más de
6 millones de personas desplazadas por
la violencia en nuestros municipios y
ciudades estas personas aunque
diferentes son tan o más vulnerables que
la población venezolana entonces no es
cierto que no hayamos manejado y
enfrentado flujos masivos de personas
vulnerables si lo hemos hecho lo que es
diferente es que este es un fenómeno que
nunca habíamos visto como región mucho
menos por una crisis en el primo rico de
la familia como era venezuela
mito 3 nos llegan los delincuentes y los
enfermos esto es tal vez uno de los
mitos que más daño hace
seguro que cuando hablamos de cuatro
millones de personas moviéndose por la
región algunos de ellos tendrán estas
características pero en realidad están
trayendo las enfermedades y el crimen a
nuestras comunidades
hablemos primero sobre los impactos de
la migración en el crimen
colombia y el perú son los únicos países
que han medido este impacto en colombia
la fundación ideas para la paz encontró
que en las áreas receptoras el crimen se
mantuvo o incluso se redujo en el perú
la policía nacional ha dicho que no es
posible evidenciar un incremento en el
crimen debido a la migración
hablemos ahora de las enfermedades sí es
cierto algunas personas migran por
motivos de salud pero en realidad la
población venezolana tiene tasas de
prevalencia de enfermedades crónicas
mucho más bajas que las de la población
nacional por ejemplo con el perú sólo
11% de la población venezolana reportó
tener estas condiciones comparados con
casi un 37 por ciento de la población
peruana
mírenlos no se ven ni muy enfermos ni
muy peligrosos verdad mito 4 nuestros
países no pueden ni tienen que
encargarse de ayudar a los venezolanos
cuando llegamos al muchos de los países
receptores la gente nos dice casi
regañadientes pero porque tenemos que
ayudar a los venezolanos nosotros
teniendo tantas necesidades el país no
puede con más
bueno en realidad los países no están
eligiendo ayudar los venezolanos primero
que los nacionales los países tienen que
hacerlo por dos razones la primera seca
un poco de su peso pero vale la pena
recordarla porque son seres humanos la
segunda es muy simple porque es lo más
beneficioso invirtiendo los venezolanos
en realidad estamos invirtiendo en el
país cuando hay un choque de precios un
link de la caída del precio del petróleo
o de los minerales el país tiene que
hacer una serie de inversiones para
adaptarse y de estas inversiones surgen
oportunidades se diversifica la economía
surgen nuevas industrias
asimismo si este choque no es de precio
si no es demográfico el país tiene que
invertir en que esta población pueda
contribuir a la economía lo antes
posible y en ese sentido este choque
aunque inesperado es ideal joven
preparado y motivado durante muchos años
venezuela fue el país más rico de
latinoamérica que invirtió en la
educación y en la salud de sus
ciudadanos a pesar de su vulnerabilidad
los venezolanos tienen mayores tasas de
preparación que la población local acá
en perú por ejemplo encontramos que el
57 por ciento de la población venezolana
cuenta con estudios superiores apoyo
consultoría estimó que esta educación le
habrá costado el perú 3.3 billones de
dólares esto es casi la tercera parte
del gasto anual en educación del país
sin embargo este potencial no se está
realizando los venezolanos tienen
generalmente calificaciones mucho
mayores que los trabajos que ejercen en
muchas dificultades para convalidar sus
estudios carecen de conexiones para
encontrar trabajo y reciben salarios
mucho más bajos que los de los
nacionales
de hecho el banco ha estimado que de
integrarse laboralmente la población
venezolana incrementaría en 1.6 por
ciento la capacidad productiva del perú
y apoyo también estimó que de recibir
salarios iguales a los de los nacionales
e incrementarían en 1.4 billones de
dólares la masa anual de lima éstos
señoras y señores es dinero contante y
sonante que utilizarían para comprar
servicios para contratar bienes
contribuyendo a la economía del país
sin embargo para poder alcanzar este
potencial debemos invertir y adaptarse
cuesta es cierto en colombia estimamos
que más o menos la provisión de
servicios a la población venezolana
costaría un 0.5 por ciento del producto
interno bruto esto es un monto
considerable pero que podría recuperarse
rápidamente debido al incremento de la
demanda agregada y del recaudo por
impuestos
de hecho acá en el perú en el 2018 se
encontró que el 8% el crecimiento del
producto interno bruto se dio gracias a
un aumento de la demanda agregada de los
venezolanos y ahora que tenemos este
conocimiento que vamos a hacer con él
porque si decidimos no hacer nada pronto
la situación se va a desbordar vamos a
tener que ir apagando incendios reales o
imaginarios según como se vayan
presentando y según como nuestras
percepciones no los hechos nos digan que
tenemos que actuar si decidimos hacer
algo tenemos dos opciones la primera es
tratar de detener su llegada imponer
visas solicitar los documentos que les
es difícil conseguir hasta pedirles que
paguen un cierto monto por pueden dar
nuestros países pero esto es como tapar
el sol con un dedo porque siendo es una
población que huye y teniendo nuestros
países fronteras tan grandes y porosas
no podemos efectivamente detener su
llegada solo podemos detener su
regularización y si no se regularizan no
contribuyen
no pueden trabajar no pagan impuestos no
ahorran ni invierten sin embargo si se
presentan mayores problemas derivados de
esta migración aparecen las redes
ilegales de tráfico de personas se dan
por ejemplo mayores explotaciones
sexuales y laborales de la población
venezolana lo que termina afectando las
condiciones laborales de los nacionales
la segunda opción es tomar el toro por
los cuernos si sabemos que esta
población va a llegar podemos entonces
decidir hacer algo para responder ante
esto
esto por ejemplo nos permitiría saber
dónde están cuántos son que saben hacer
y con eso tomar decisiones de política
que nos permitan aprovechar al máximo su
potencial también podríamos entender
mejor cómo este fenómeno afecta a las
áreas receptoras ayudándonos a canalizar
inversiones para responder a estas
necesidades pero y entonces que se hace
no puede ser como le dice cerebro pinto
lo mismo de todas las noches no
necesitamos un plan diferente y para
formular este plan necesitamos empezar
por entender la situación en colombia en
noviembre del año pasado el banco
mundial publicó un reporte que analiza
las implicaciones de este éxodo en el
país con base en este reporte el
gobierno formuló una política nacional
de respuesta que se encuentra
actualmente bajo implementación un
análisis similar está a punto de ser
publicado para perú y otro más será
publicado pronto para ecuador lo cual le
daría herramientas a estos países para
formular un plan de respuesta
y qué elementos tiene este plano este
plan tiene acciones en cuatro áreas
primordiales que permitirán dar una
respuesta humana y humanitaria a este
éxodo creando oportunidades de
desarrollo primero se deben adaptar las
instituciones y las leyes para poder
hacer frente a este fenómeno esto
incluye por ejemplo generar mecanismos
de respuestas multisectoriales
coordinados como es la gerencia de
fronteras en colombia o generar
instrumentos migratorios adaptados a las
realidades de esta población como son
los permisos de permanencia que han
creado perú y colombia- permitiendo la
regularización de más de un millón y
medio de venezolanos segundo debe
aumentar la capacidad de respuesta a las
áreas receptoras esto incluye por
ejemplo ampliar la oferta de servicios
como salud o educación invertir en
infraestructura e invertir en la
dinamización de la economía como lo
están haciendo jordania el líbano en
respuesta a la crisis siria
tercero se deben mitigar las
vulnerabilidades y los riesgos para la
población venezolana asociados con este
éxodo esto incluye acciones como por
ejemplo facilitar su convalidación de
títulos ayudarles a encontrar un mejor
empleo pero también incluye crear rutas
diferenciadas de atención para población
particularmente vulnerable como son las
mujeres los niños separados la población
indígena y la población lgp y finalmente
se debe trabajar en crear un pacto
social a nivel regional nacional y local
esto es trabajar conjuntamente con
múltiples países para poder mejorar la
distribución de la población en varios
de ellos evitando que los impactos se
concentren en uno solo también incluye
por ejemplo generar diálogos nacionales
y trabajar con las comunidades de
acogida para que ellas puedan apreciar
mejor las oportunidades detrás de este
fenómeno y quien se encarga de todo esto
el gobierno obvio nos encanta culpar el
gobierno de todo lo que se hace y lo que
no otros sospechosos de siempre son la
economía que financia la respuesta y la
sociedad que lo recibe o no son estas
cosas que mágicamente se ocupan de todo
sin embargo el gobierno la economía y la
sociedad somos todos todos y cada uno de
nosotros sentados en esta sala
conectados por internet y viendo este
vídeo
somos nosotros quienes le exigimos al
gobierno que tenga una política activa
de respuesta preparando nuestras
instituciones nuestras sociedades y
nuestras comunidades para poder hacer
frente a este fenómeno somos nosotros
vecinos recibiendo los en nuestras
comunidades ayudándolos a encontrar una
vivienda digna amoblar sus casas a
encontrar un trabajo y colegio para sus
hijos somos nosotros empresarios
ofreciéndoles trabajo en las mismas
condiciones y en los mismos términos de
ley que la población local somos
nosotros medios de comunicación
periodistas ciudadanos del común
diseminando información objetiva y
denunciando la diseminación de
información xenófoba que nutre todos
estos mitos que tanto daño nos hacen
somos nosotros padres de familia
recibiendo los con empatía y solidaridad
en el colegio de nuestros hijos como en
un colegio en tumbes en donde los
escoltas venezolanos pueden
con orgullo símbolos patrios de su país
venezuela y de su país pero somos
nosotros ecuatorianos colombianos y
peruanos aceptando que siguiéramos a
nuestros hijos tener tanta hambre que a
los diez meses pesan tanto como un
recién nacido como lo vimos en rioacha
en la guajira también habríamos venido
hasta aquí buscando devolver la
esperanza
de la forma en que nosotros de manera
individual y colectiva respondamos a
esta situación depende el futuro de
todos estos seres humanos que seamos
honestos en el pasado recibieron a
muchos colombianos huyendo del conflicto
hermano y a muchos peruanos huyendo de
la hiperinflación y del terrorismo de la
forma en que nosotros respondamos a esto
de nosotros de nadie más depende que
este cambio sea una oportunidad para
todos muchas gracias
[Música]